hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round 4 of the
2018 grand KHS classic between Fabiano
Khurana
world chess championship Challenger and
a lot in German author by Johnny
Grandmaster Arkady in a ditch he's
originally from Latvia from 2005 to 2015
he represented Germany and as of them
until today he represents Azerbaijan so
quite a colorful grandmaster and there's
a reason why I decided to show you this
game I will not tell you which reason
that is what you're welcome to try and
take a guess in the comments section
below and I don't have any photos of
this encounter
it seems the the grand K video
production team is taking a rest even
after the rest day but maybe I will have
some photos tomorrow we'll see I did
prepare the standings after round 4 but
I will show you those after the game so
let's see the game Fabi opens would be
four we have E 5 Knight to f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 so the rule opus Knight
to f6 Knight H goes for the Berlin
defence D 3 and d 6
we have castles Bishop to d7 rook to e1
Bishop to e7 c3 knowledge castles we
have h3 and rook to e8 and here a4 far
we could have gone for Bishop to g5
immediately but he he's waiting to see
what what knowledge will do as he did to
play rook to e8 he's preparing Bishop to
f8 so first Fabi wants him to play
Bishop to f8 and only then will he go
for Bishop to g5 so we do have Bishop to
f8 Bishop to g5 and h6 much of to h4 and
here g5 a very provocative move but can
certainly play here Bishop back to e7
and wait to see what white will what
white will decide to do here but he
doesn't he he decides to go for the very
active g5 so Bishop to g3 the knight to
e7 now offering to trade bishops and
Fabi Fabi
trades bishops he considered not not
trading bishops consider leaving the
bishops on the board as he did say so in
the interview after the game but he says
it's perfectly fine to do it immediately
Queen captures and
B to D to 9th to g6 and now Knight to c4
here he says that it was very hard for
him to find a plan Knight to c4 is
certainly an idea he that considered d4
but he didn't he didn't know if it was
okay for white to actually start opening
up the century immediately and another
thing he thought about was nice to f1
night to f1 would the idea that after
rook is developed to d8 then he can go
Queen to b3 and after black decides
where he will defend the b7 pawn we are
c6 or something then he can go rook a to
D one with his a rook but okay those
were some of the options Fabi considered
and he decided for four nights the c4
rook a to the 8th we have in Knights the
e3 and d5 now and d5 is a is a very
weird move Bobby says that he couldn't
understand what's the idea behind the d5
but he simply decided to capture the
pawn he wanted to see what will happen
so E captor Sun d5 and Bishop to g7 so
this is purely purely an intuitive point
sacrifice which which Fabi didn't expect
and here D for D for Fabi here did
consider night the c4 but after Knight
to c4 he didn't really find any ideas
after E 4 for example D captures on e4
Knight captures and he for Queen to d3
but now f5 and this night is very very
unpleasant for white honey for the
Bushman g3 as is not not the best piece
black can always capture and mess up the
white pawn structure on the Kings side
so he didn't like this position so after
Bishop to g7 d4 we have he captures on
d4 and now C capture somebody for this
is this is probably the best for white
seek after some beforehand twin capture
some before knife capture son d4 not so
much because here black simply gets too
much after Knight captures and Knight
captures Queen captures rook captures
rook captures and after Bishop captures
on c7 here black has this nice stage 4
move threatening checkmate and g2 and
here you have to do a lot of calculation
is it okay to play if
I do even want to play f3 do you want to
play Knight to f3 allow the exchange of
Queens if you play Queen to f1 then like
and simply capture on before and after
captures captures perfectly fine
position for black so after he captures
on d4 we have C captors on d4 and Knight
captures on d5 here Knight to e4 seems
like a very dangerous idea but after
Knight to e5 it's actually white that
will get an advantage because after
Knight captures the Bishop captures you
can't really you can't really go for
Bishop captures on e5 so you'd have to
go f6 and after f3 attacking the knight
the here comes Knight to f2 King
captures not capturing the bishop on e5
and after pawn captures Bishop captures
and Queen to d3 black it's not a very
comfortable position for black the d5
pawn is very safe here threatening Queen
to g6 the rook is coming to d1 where it
will support the pawn so you're not
gonna be able to win it so after this C
captures on d4 we have Knight captures
and now Knight captures on d5
rook captures any one Queen captures any
one and Queen captures on d5 and here
Fabi definitely does have time to
capture the pawn and it's the only move
that gives white some advantage so
Bishop captures and c7 attacking the
rook we have looked to see it attacking
the bishop wrote to c1 defending it and
here Bishop captures on d5 and e4 this
move focuses he didn't expect this move
for some reason he didn't consider it
but okay white is still fine here Queen
to d2 now pinning the bishop and now
Queen to d7 this is why this is why he
missed it
now if you captured the bishop a black
and simply captured this bishop so knife
capture son before rook captures on c7
rook captures and Queen captures on c7
and now Knight to f5 into h7 we have g3
and here
Fabi says that he had like 18 minutes on
the clock in this position and that
night ich had 22
and here NIDA she was trying to probably
calculate a force to draw or something
but he he couldn't find it and here he
he totally burned all of his time and he
got into serious time trouble here if
you go Knight to e7 trying to exchange
Knights here simply Knight to d6
and again black is in a lot of trouble
here another thing after this position
as it is very hard for black to find the
move Knight which played nice to e5 and
the Caruana characterizes this move as a
mistake
even though Knight 3/5 is the engine's
second favorite choice here I saw an
interview after the game with Fabi
Bobby says 925 is no mistake a king a
queen to c6 I would have been better and
the indeed Queen to c6 is the engines
favorite choice so you can see how
strong and well-prepared Bobby Bobby is
and with what strength he is playing
this tournament he is definitely here to
win it so a knife to e5 by night each
and it's not a mistake but it's
interesting that far we saw the second
the engine's second favorite choice as a
mistake
Queen to e3 and now Knight the c4 and
here Bobby says he didn't really
understand the knight the c4 okay yes
you're attacking my queen you're
attacking my pawn but even if I play
pawn to d3 or you're never allowed to
capture the point simply Queen to d4
attacks your knight and threatens to
checkmate this dis loses so he didn't
want to calculate this too much sauce
after and after Knight to c4 he simply
played Queen to see three immediately
threatening checkmate Queen to e5
defending so now if if Queen captures
knighted and Queen captures neither on
f5 and here a queen to d3 Queen to c2
seems also like a very reasonable choice
but here black has this Queen captures
on b2 now forcing a trade of Queens and
if white refuses
for example Queen to d3 now comes Queen
to see one check King h2 and now Queen
to d2 again offering offering a trade of
Queens and now if you capture the knight
Soviet Queen captures an f2 with check
King moves Queen captures on f5 and now
it's actually white
losing here so after Queen e5 Queen to D
3 by Fabi we have night capture Sun b2
and this night capture some b2 will will
be one of the reasons black lost this
game because the night is now simply too
far away from from all the action quinta
c2 still threatening some discoveries
Queen to e1 check King to g2 and now
Queen to d1 again with the idea that if
Fabi captures the knight then Queen to
d5 check winning winning the knight on
f5 so here Queen to e4 Queen to b4 still
not allowing any tricks and still
threatening some some some discoveries
and here comes the final mistake here an
adage was so low on time that he
couldn't find the correct move
he played Queen captures on a4 with the
idea that still there are no discoveries
a trade of Queens is offered here but he
missed Fabiano's idea here the only move
that really does hold the draw for black
here ice queen a queen to d7 but it's
it's such a complicated move that even
Fabian in his recap of the game in an
interview after didn't really think that
Queen d7 could hold but 27 does hold as
white doesn't have a good discovery here
and after you play a move like 93 which
Fabi did suggest after after the game
for something like into King to g8
Knight to d5 threatening Knight to f6
with would check here black black can't
hold with Queen captures on a4 again
threatening a trade a trade of Queens
and the white doesn't have anything here
Knight f6 check King moves Knight h5
check King moves and now after Queen
captures some b7 this is the move Black
has to find Queen to c2 now but finding
this in serious time trouble that night
each was in isn't really possible here
why doesn't have a way to continue the
attack you would have to settle for some
perpetual checks if you go screen
captures on a seven tries to equalize
material then Queen to c6 check King g1
and the Queen to f3 will be sufficient
for black
for black to to get to to achieve a draw
so after this Queen to f4
after this Queen to e5 an Irish played
Queen captures on e4 I thinking that
it's basically the same idea but he
missed fabi's excellent Queen captures
on b7 now threatening the night here and
threatening the f7 pawn and here it's
very it's very difficult to to actually
play this if you play Queen to c4 which
seems like an interesting idea you're
defending the f7 pawn you're allowing
White's to capture B tonight and then
you have an eye to e4 check threat
capturing the f5 night unfortunately it
doesn't work because of 93 this attacks
your queen there are no checks you can
give as the White Queen is covering this
entire diagonal and after you defend the
night simply Queen captures on f7 and
after you block with the Queen Queen to
a5 check Queen locks Queen to d7 check
Queen blocks and now Queen to c6 with
the terrible threat of Knight to f5 you
have to prevent this and now I have to
point to g6 now Queen to c7 wins as now
you definitely win this night inner King
to h8 or King to g8 will lose the Queen
to be checked picking up the night and
if you block then Queen to c2 check
again picks up the night
so after this Queen capture some b7
queen to a2 was played now defending the
knight here and also guarding the f7
pawn but now the Queen and Knight are
placed simply so poorly that favi
doesn't have any problems playing this
night to e3 acting to g7 now Queen to b4
Queen to be one and now g4 preparing to
create an outpost for this night on f5
King to g8 now Knight comes to f5 Queen
to c2
Queen to be 8 and here our King to H
King to h7 Queen to b7 and here came to
h8 going for one last trick if father
captures Queen cappers on f7 then how
Queen to b4 check will will give black
some chances may be to find a draw and
maybe some perpetual
wherever King goes there are a lot of
squares where the black queen can check
the white king but after this King to h8
move Fabi simply played Queen to e7 and
it was in this position that Arcadian
idak resigned in the game
the threat is of course Quinta Queen to
f8 check followed by Queen to g7
checkmate and if you prevent this with
the only possible move order there is
Quintus e6 check King moves and now
Queen to g6 now simply Queen to e5 wins
as after you move the King you lose the
knight on b2 and it's game over so yeah
after Queen to e7 and I teach to resign
the game and a very nice with victory
for World Chess Champion June Challenger
Fabiano Caruana and before I forget I
will just show you the standings after
round 4 we do have Fabiano Caruana in
first place with 3 points out of 4 also
Maxim Bashir and Nikita be to go have
three points out of 4 so very crowded in
shirt first place and all of them have a
rating of almost 2,900 with Maxim Bashir
have a rating performance of over 2,900
then with two and a half points Iranian
and Carlson with one and a half point
Anand and blue bomb and with one point
- Guru Meyer and ARCA denied it that was
this game against Fabiano Caruana so
every interesting tournament and a very
interesting turn of events so far I do
have a question for you do you think
Fabiana will continue his streak or do
you think that he does have the fear
Carlsen as you all know that Carson
usually loses a game or two at the
beginning of the tournament and then
wins the tournament in the end and now
he started the tournament without
actually losing any games so will this
mean that he will be even more dangerous
later on in the tournament so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
probably tomorrow we'll have some nice
photos for you to enjoy but until then
you know I will have to just settle for
the old school way without photos I
would like to thank an unknown person
for a contribution to my channel thank
you I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think over
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you